hello grammarians hello rosie hi david
how are you good how are you good today
we are going to talk about run-ons and
comma splices
so a run-on sentence is what happens
when two independent clauses are put
together in one sentence without any
punctuation or coordinating conjunctions
like and but or so
rosie what is a good example of a run-on
sentence
we bought nails we bought a hammer yeah
so we can see
that this sentence contains two
um
two individual independent clauses so
we've got number one
we bought nails number two we bought a
hammer now there are a couple of
different ways we could make this a
legal sentence but right now as it
stands this is a run-on right so there
are a couple ways we could fix this
sentence um one way would be just to add
a semicolon in there
so you've got two independent clauses we
bought nails semicolon we bought a
hammer right
another way you could do that would be
to just add a comma and then the
conjunction and so you're connecting
those two
clauses so this is a run-on sentence
without this and and this comma and it's
called that because it's sort of like a
runaway train right you know it doesn't
have enough stoppage in it
it's how i would put it so that's what a
run-on sentence is now i want to talk
about comma splicing and the word splice
not a super common term if you are
neither a sailor or a film editor
but splicing is a word that originally
meant to take two ropes untangle them
and weave them back together it's a
sailor's term related to rope lines in
our case for grammar
a splice a comma splice is an
inappropriate joining of two independent
clauses by using a comma so
so
rosie this is little tony crime fighting
pony right so for example in this
sentence i love lil tony 2 pony up to
the streets it's my favorite movie in
the little tony franchise
very fine series of non-existent films
the problem with this sentence is that
right now it's got this comma in the
middle of it
and this comma inappropriately joins
these two
independent clauses oh and this whole
time
i forgot to say
two independent clauses inappropriately
joined by a comma so okay so we've got
independent clause number one remember
this thing could stand on its own as a
sentence i love the name of this movie i
love little tony two pony up to the
streets that could be its own sentence
on its own end it with a period period
it's my favorite movie in the little
tony franchise period but we have these
two independent clauses right um we
cannot join them with just a comma
we could say i love little tony two pony
up to the streets comma and it's my
favorite movie in the little tony
franchise or as we did in the previous
example we could also throw in a
semicolon which is i think what i would
rather do i love little tony two pony up
to the streets semicolon it's my
favorite movie in the little tony
franchise and rosie you will notice that
i have underlined these uh these titles
oh yes because these are the names of
published works
right even though we made them up
exactly but okay but for real i would
love to see like a little tony crime
fighting pony
totally so to review
um
when you're looking at a run-on you're
looking at two independent clauses that
are together in one sentence that are
joined inappropriately without
punctuation or conjunctions
so we bought nails we bought a hammer
there's there's not really a place to
know
where the division between clauses is
in that
uh and so the thing to do is to either
is to add some kind of is to add a comma
uh and some and a conjunction
or to combine them using a semicolon the
same deal with a comma splice it's just
that a comma splice
is a run-on that hasn't been fixed all
the way
right the comma is being used but we
need some bigger punctuation
in place of the comma something like a
semicolon
uh in order to make a distinction
between those two independent clauses
so that is how you identify and fix
run-ons and comma splices you can learn
anything david out rosie out